who created unrealistic dating
expectations we have today where did it
come from
the women women I mean let's not pretend
I mean what happens is women will go
through trauma make poor decisions and
what they do instead of changing and
growing they will say well I have to
level up and I have to pick I have to
they add more standards to what their
the men that they choose instead of
saying something's wrong with me I need
to take accountability and the choices
that I've made they will turn around and
say no the men need to jump through
higher Hoops now I come now with more
trauma baggage probably kids and
everything else but these men still I'm
now as I age I'm getting better like
fine wine I'm getting better like wine
and so they think that they keep raising
these standards and Men across the board
almost every man I talk to they for a
woman whose mind is right they were
lower looks they were lower in every
category I have yet to meet a woman out
the bag that will say that they will for
their standards to get a certain type of
quality the only time a woman lowers her
standards in terms of looks and
character and all of this stuff that
they claim is when he has money I'm
going to offer a different perspective
sorry I'm gonna play Devil's Advocate
yeah I was about to and the thing is is
that like if you look at patriarchal
regimes across our world right now women
can't create anything without a man yeah
nothing they can't create anything they
can't just step out of nowhere and just
create feminism feminism has to be
supplanted by men it has to be
undefended but what percent of men
partic part took in making those laws
versus what percent of women
participated in it listen I think I
think a lot of men I think I think
listen at the end of the day there's
things get shifted and changed due to
money and men wanting vagina that's why
they say [__] runs the world because of
simp ass men that can't control the
goddamn eggplant [__] don't change in
here without men [__] will never change
in those other patriarchal regimes
unless men allow it to can I tell you
all the inventions that make women's
lives easier now were created by men
tampons were created by a man women can
vote because of men no actually because
men joined that and so a lot of times
we'll say that men are this way men are
that but they never give voice to the
men that actually created things and
enjoined you know with women to to help
create things so it's like they just
throw men and men don't have a desire to
put women down like they don't even
think of us in that way like it feels
good
let's talk about it so they don't have
like I think women have this idea that
men just are thinking about how they can
they can you know oppress us and and do
all this to us when every every even the
C-section created by a man to save
women's lives if you actually go through
history the majority of things that
actually benefit women today that we
take for granted and and the same woman
will blame a man for for getting
pregnant but to say another man created
the C-section so you and your baby
wouldn't lose their life and so we we
don't think of these things but we I
don't know it's just emotional talk we
just say men are just men are the blame
for everything let's just let's just put
it out there to kind of answer your
question right
[Music]
change the game when men decided that
they've got a load of money in their
pocket and they decided to start flying
women out and they decided to start
paying for everything for women because
they had it what did what did Lil Wayne
said it ain't tricking if you got it
yeah it is that's what he said right he
said it's not chicken if you got it so
these rich rappers who were still simps
but they had a lot of money started to
change the game because a lot of women
started to go to these concerts go to
these rappers and these rappers would
pay for everything they'd fly them out
they'd do all of this kind of stuff and
then those women started to think oh
yeah okay well so-and-so flew me out so
and so gave me money so and so done that
for me and so rich simp men also had a
hand do you know it wasn't the rappers
it was the R B singers well them too
whoever they started at the RnB started
do you think it's really simping if he
gets sex out of it yeah because I was
done you know what I mean like is it
really simping today
wait wait wait so if money if no money
is nothing to Drake and he he spends
money to fly a girl out like the money's
nothing to him and he gets sex with this
girl he wanted to have sex with yeah and
I still think it starts with the women
because they have to accept it there's
plenty of Sims that get pity viscous
innards yeah but but people but people
like Drake people like Drake who have
money he might have game right but when
you've got money you don't necessarily
need game you just got money right so a
poor guy he's got nothing but you said
it was rich simps who did it and I said
is he really a simp if he's flying her
out you know yeah I would say he was
I would say it was like there's
this is going to say oh yeah let me fly
around why would you fly a vagina out
when his vagina right there
[Music]
and if you said if all you had to do was
tell your PA hey I want this girl at
this time pull like pull the money on my
credit cards
in the market but that's why I said it's
spoiling the market so so those guys
types of guys they spoiled the
markets
how many are rappers I feel like that's
the same argument to say well it's these
these five percent of guys and it's not
even five percent of guys who are
rappers it's a very small handful of
guys who are rappers who actually do
that I would it expands Beyond it
and why do we say that they spoil the
market instead of the women spoil
themselves
he didn't spoil [__]
gets thrown around without like a
tangible definition so like personally I
don't think that if you're a billionaire
you buy a chicken or even a millionaire
you fly a chick out with like a you know
150 ticket round-trip on Spirit that'll
make you no goddamn set at all okay and
you're not even tricking either because
the average average date nowadays in
America right
[Music]
indirect anyway uh case in point
um I just don't think that it's
necessarily um I understand your point
my G but I don't think it's necessarily
a simple to me Sim is petalizing a woman
uh thinking that she is the prize
without her proving anything right like
just thinking that you just owe her the
world Diamonds and Pearls she deserves
this and she hasn't proved what happened
again is petalizing it doesn't
necessarily mean paying for a a trip for
her to come over here and Slob On My
Knob like cold
yeah I would just just offered that and
I guess I would ask the question so the
women that are in this group that are
getting food out are they the same pool
of women that would date an average man
it goes back to that 80 20. are they
there's always going to be you know the
man with a lot of money the woman that
he's going to want to you know pick for
this day of the week but we're talking
about everyday average like I can't take
you on a date because you have
ridiculous expectations is it that same
group I think I think average women have
because average women are accessed by
those top percent of men right
um those average women can get sex by
this top percent of men because those
top percent of men don't feel any way to
have sex with a woman who's a two to a
woman who's a 10 right so what it does
is that it spoils the market because
these women who are fives think they
deserve what the 10 gets right because
they were accessed by a 10 by a top tier
man they were accessed by him and then
now she runs around thinking oh those
average dudes are way are they're weak
they're whack it's like no that's who
you are they set their new barometer
because a man will sleep with you
um who is higher up you think that
that's your new set point like a lot of
women will raise their standard well now
because this man slept with me he just
was a f boy he was playing around but
now I can attain that type of man as a
husband as who will wife me you can't
and they actually will start to get run
through by these men or try to enable
put down average men who are on their
level and look look at them as lower and
the reality is that causes you to lose
and I mean even this whole conversation
is not to put women down it is not to
it's to say listen there are guys who
are up at this level they are sleeping
with you girl but they are not going to
wife you they're sleeping with you
because it's easy to do you should be
upset with them not us for telling you
the truth but they you raise your
standard to something that's not you
will never get the results that you want
and then we want you to get the results
so I'm I have a question
um for the older women on the panel
um when do you think women start to
lower their standards if ever
at what age
I didn't want to believe it when I heard
Kevin Samuel say 60 because I thought
that was so far off but I really do
believe because we have this thing you
know black don't crack or whatever I'm
still 47 in three years I'll be half a
hundred I should move differently than
someone that's 27 so I would say women
mistakenly think
I can still compete in that Arena so I
shouldn't have to settle and then you
end up in your 50s and 60s alone and
then you say okay I'll just be happy to
have anyone she's she's telling the
truth so I'm 41 and this is the reality
I I have young guys I mean like young
like Ballers NBA like guys who are like
early 20s who will hit me up want to
take me out and all of this and a lot of
women who still can carry a little bit
as they get older they're still in shape
they're getting hit up by these young
guys and you think you still have it
because these guys will want to sleep
with you they'll even take you out there
I mean they'll even buy you something to
do they're not going to marry you and a
lot of women just like the glamor of it
and they feel like they still got it and
they don't realize these guys are just
using you for easy sex and so because
they're sleeping with you and they're
attracted to you that translates in your
mind that I got it like I'm still in the
game I know women who are like 50 and
older who actually look amazing like no
lie like I know these women I have women
in my family who look this way and if
they wanted to most of the women in my
family are married but if they wanted to
they they could attract they're 50 they
can attract a 30 year old guy and so it
is not until they hit where it starts to
crack and and guys are just like man 60
uh they can't do that it at six that six
puts a hurt even if a guy wanted to I
was just gonna say they can attract him
but they can't keep him and ultimately
that's what we want at the end of the
day we're not just supposed to be out
here floating around from man to man we
are supposed to be tethered and attached
and belong to someone and I think that's
normal and that's natural we just have
to do a better job of making the
distinction between attention and an
intention that's right sexual sexual is
sexual attraction versus relationship
intention and a lot of women cannot tell
the difference so I'm curious you said
you're 21 yeah would you say what
they're talking about do you see that
with your friends where they'll sleep
with someone that's out of their league
or that someone famous will DM them yeah
and you know it happens it's happened to
me but because I know they're rappers
footballers basketball players I'm just
not into that because I know that
they're not going to be available to me
so but my friends on the other hand
they're more
yeah well they um fly out to someone
where they don't know yeah I'm curious
and you don't have to say this if you
don't want to how many guys has a girl
your age slept with usually like not you
but just in general
um
now around 15. oh my God are you 21
month yeah so she's not even 21 yet guys
and you would say the average girl I'm
not saying me personally it's only been
one but yeah but girls your age it's
like 15 to 20. yeah plus two years and
how many how many did were they in
relationships with
none it's mainly situationships now so
you know shout out to feminism and would
you would you agree that it's like
mostly the same guys that they're all
sleeping with yeah but then every time
someone does them run back they start
catching feelings the sky is like okay
well I don't want a relationship with
you they're like okay I'm gonna up my
standards wow and then to wear why do I
love her so much guys she's so pretty
too thank you sorry go okay keep talking
sorry she is so cute yeah they um they
up their standards and
when there's someone that like maybe a
rapper footballer messages them they're
just like they hop on it and then it's
like a cycle the same thing happens
where that guy just doesn't want her for
what she wants and do most of the time
do the men tell the women up front that
they're not looking for anything yeah
but they still believe that I can change
it yeah feminism
would you agree that it's mostly on the
women then because the guy said up front
what they're looking for yeah as many of
you know I was just ban on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible